27 year old right-hander zach eflin
tonight yeah he's uh very underrated
averaging sixth and two-thirds so an
inning horse in today's game sinker
cutter
under-reported curveball you'll see a
lot of those tonight and a change up to
the lefties jeff mcneal about to dig in
on the left side against the righty zach
keflan and mcneil sends that one the
other way to mccutcheon
for the first out of the night
one up one down and francisco lindor is
gonna be the better but for the most
part he thinks he's close
and uh he's working hard every day
and he struck him out
this is a pitch that's giving him
trouble all year long as a fastball up
is a cutter 89 miles an hour
and is a pitch he cannot lay off two up
two down michael conforto coming up
conforto hits it on the ground to the
left side and on through a base hit
going into left field past the diving
third baseman alec baum and conforto
who's really starting to swing the bat
better now is a board with a two out
single and that'll bring up pete alonso
bounce towards short dd charges gloves
it knee high transfers throws on the run
he got him and a one pitch out to retire
alonso and that'll do it for the mets
left-hander david peterson former first
rounder who pitched last on tuesday and
was a tough luck two-to-one loser
against the red sox a lot of ground ball
outs for david that game he's made two
starts against the phillies
one not so good and one terrific back on
april 14 struck out a career-high tying
10. here's andrew mccutchen there's a
few guys in his lineup that need to get
it going and catches one up mccutcheon
puts a charge in a ball and sends it to
deep center field and that one's gone
and andrew mccutchen has put the
phillies on top with a lead off home run
and the phillies lead one nothing and
here's rhys hoskins a right-handed power
hitter and there's ball
and so the phillies with a base runner a
run in nobody out and bryce harper
coming up his first at-bat since getting
hit in the face at 97 miles an hour
wednesday night in st louis and harper's
support with the base hit the phillies
have a homer a walk and a single to
begin the bottom of the first inning and
now jt ray lamuto will be back after
missing a couple of days with a hand
injury swung on and missed strike three
peterson went away there one huge help
so here is alec baume the third baseman
right hand better infield up the middle
and double play depth back up the middle
but smothered by mcneal to lindor for
one the relay they get him both wow
that was an absolute rocket back up the
middle a brilliant double play turned by
the mets saddam smith leads off the
second the pitch to smith
is lifted in the air to left field
pretty deep mccutchen back onto the
track reaches up can't get it goes off
his glove picks up the camera in front
of the warning track and cruising into
second with a double is dom smith that's
a ball that mccutchen probably should
have caught but results in a long two
base hit for smith so lead off hit her
in scoring position now for kevin pillar
hey pallar lines that one right back up
the middle
here comes don smith
[Applause]
time to get him roman quinn
firing home to get dominic smith well
that's a great throw right there
especially with no outs you don't want
to make the first out at home plate with
a struggling offense young mr peterson
who will face dede gregorius to lead off
it's in there for a call at strike three
peterson picks up his second strikeout
is now retired three in a row one man
away and that will bring up nick maton
the second baseman hung on and missed
strike three to slide her away and
peterson has his third strikeout swung
peterson gets him with a fastball david
peterson strikes out the side two down
neal still at second and conforto will
back breaking ball hitting the air
toward right that falls for a base hit
harper dropped the ball in right mcneil
scores standing up the mets tie the game
at one on conforto's rbi single here's
pete alonzo now alonso it's a broken bat
chopper toward third boom charges and he
mops it everybody's gonna be saved alec
bone normally a short-handed third
baseman charging that slow hit roller
couldn't make the play and that's now
with a chance to put up a crooked number
now runners on first and second with two
outs for dominic smith the mets have
five hits in this game against zach
keplin swinging a miss he's struck him
out he got him with a curveball and zach
keflan puts out the fire david peterson
has struck out four including all three
in the bottom of the second now he'll
face the pitcher eflin efflin swings and
misses strike three at a high fastball
so that's four straight strikeouts for
peterson
it's in there strike three called at the
knees mccutchen took a few steps toward
first now he's running all the way
toward first before finally peeling off
at the last moment mccutchen making it
even more obvious that he did not like
that call home plate umpire andy
fletcher is hearing it from the phillies
dugout as well hoskins and harper reach
back to back just like they did in the
first the inning continues for jt rio
mutu he lifts a high fly deep toward
right center conforto's back on the
track reaches up makes the catch just
before backing into the fence in deep
right center yamuto drove it a long way
but he's out to win the inning you get
the lead off double a single by pilar
strikeout and effluent can escape this
with one well-timed ground ball and now
james mckenna was a double play
candidate and there's a grounder back to
the mound knocked down by eflin goes
wide to second it's caught well off the
back by gregorius smith scores mccann on
it first with a bit of a gift as the mix
have taken a 2-1 lead that could have
been the double play ball the phillies
were hoping for it would have been an
inning ending double play and that loads
the bases for francisco lindor
one for 14 this year with runners in
scoring position oh for his last 15.
and lindor pops it up
harper's got it
and the mets leave them loaded that's
him now left nine men on base the
phillies are in business runners at the
corners and one away phillies needs
something here from dede gregorius
struggled mightily of late here's dede
now lean into it got him
and dede has done it a three-run home
run for d.d gregorius and he has turned
the game around brandon kitzler's on the
bound lars leading off lauren trying to
get the mix going and palora lines it in
the air deep to left back by the wall
it's gone
kevin pallar with his third hit of the
game and now it's a one-run game as the
phillies lead is cut to four to three
and it's an infield single for vr the
tying runs on base and the 1-2 to peraza
shot past hoskins that ball laid him up
vr to third
vr
we are tied
and jonathan vr with some superbly alert
base running that's as embarrassing for
a defender as the hidden ball trick
they've got the bases loaded one out and
michael conforto coming up and you know
conforto would love to do something
special here against alvarado given the
past
and it is low ball four it forces in a
run the mets are leading by a score of
five to four still have the bases loaded
still only one out and they have a five
to four lead for pete alonso who's
coming up next and hale's first pitch
lined in the air to right center that's
a base hit and that's going all the way
to the wall
with all three
and standing at second with the
three-run double is peter lonzo and the
mitz have taken an 8-4 lead here in the
eighth inning edwin d has a look to shut
things down here in the night
6.50 era and a one and three record
lifetime against the fields it's an
eight to five ball game phillies will
bring the tying run to the plate hoskins
is old for nine in his career against
edwin diaz 2-1 pitch to hoskins
and it's gone
i do not think that's a homer i think it
hit the top railing oh my goodness
they're saying it hit the top of the
wall not a home run this has become one
absolutely bizarre game in philadelphia
something happened edwin diaz and he's
hurt and now it's jerry's familia
hingary is the tying man at second and
now it's harper now he's trying to bring
the tying around home he is the winning
run at the plate here's the 2-2 pitch to
harper
swung on him miss strike three put it in
the books and the mets hold on to take
this series in philadelphia
[Music]